uh john barnes welcome to you um
was this somebody been incredibly candid
about an awful moment in their life
or is this beyond the pale well first of
all i just want you to give me a few
minutes because i believe that
liam neeson deserves a medal and i'll
tell you why liam
neeson i've listened to the whole i've
listened to the whole transcript liam
neeson
was talking about his his film revenge
and he's talking about revenge doesn't
do anyone any good he mentions the fact
that
being brought up in northern ireland he
understands how destructive that can be
he went on to tell a story of a
situation whereby a friend of his had
been raped
now if you listen to everything he's
talking about he's talking about
in the moment and you can't blame them
leonis for thinking what he feels
because this is what and this is a while
ago
this is what society has shown him that
black people do muslims do
this is what society has wrongly shown
him this is what the media have wrongly
portrayed
to him so in that moment he said for a
week he was going around
looking to to kill a black person or a
black and he did that in quotation marks
now what he actually went on to say is
what he was ashamed
and horrified by the way he felt yes
he's not ashamed and horrified and
wanted to commit
the act of revenge he's ashamed and
horrified because that
is what he thought about all black
people after a week he realized he was
wrong
that is what he said i'm ashamed and
horrified of the way i felt
now depending on how you want to spin
this story now it's about
he was going to kill a black person we
want to eventually
we want to think about it and ventilate
it it's an important subject no no
no no no it's been spun it's been spun
because
if you want to think about what he's
actually saying the context which is why
he then said to the lady
he said to the lady in his voice i um
i've got a particular set of skills if
you don't report this in the way that it
is meant
now we're talking about and he's trying
to kill the woman what he's actually
saying is that he's horrified
and ashamed of the way he felt he went
on to say that
that is exactly what he went on to say
which meant that he was ashamed of the
way he felt
but you cannot blame him for thinking
that because i said earlier with the
whole raheem sterling talking about the
influence the media has
you cannot blame people for thinking
muslims because of muslim grooming gangs
jamaican yadi ganz then look at muslims
and jamaicans in a negative light and
he's admitting that that is the way he
viewed it
so for this one black person who raped
this woman he then
looked at it from the perspective of all
black people are racists now what he's
actually saying is that this is what i
thought this is what i saw
and i am ashamed and horrified and after
a week i
said to myself what am i doing that is
that is the reality behind it
as much as people are now jumping on
this bandwagon of how terrible it is
what he's done he's come out and he's
told the truth
now the big problem we have is when
people are afraid to admit the way they
actually feel
everybody's now going to say oh if he
had said i have more respect for him now
than had he come out and said i viewed
all black people as equal i just view
everybody as equal
what he said was for a week because of
the stress i was under
when my friend was raped by a black
person
and because of what the narrative around
black people
and muslims and this is many years ago
surrounding the perception we have of
them
i then wanted to kill every black person
because as far as i'm concerned as i was
taught
black people are racist he said he was
horrified and ashamed for thinking that
but that is not the story we're telling
we now want him to be pilloried we want
to never let him work again
people are now going to be afraid to
tell the truth and how they feel and i
always say we are all unconscious racist
and he said unconsciously for a week and
a half that's how he felt
we have people who have been doing it
and keeping it quiet for 20 years but as
long as you don't admit it
then we think everything is okay now the
big problem we have as this
witch hunt is now going to stop the
process of people now
as in rwanda keep talking about our
truth and reconciliation let's hold our
hands up and say i'm unconsciously
racist
don't blame me this is what i've been
wrongly told which is what he's been
said and he's ashamed and embarrassed by
it so why is he being pilloried for it
there's so much going on there isn't
there it's important as you say to see
the context the whole thing not just
look at the 15 second sound bite see the
context
of the whole thing try and appreciate
the nuance and in a sense
that idea of sharing thoughtfully very
candidly a stream of consciousness as
you say
if we want to ventilate sensitive issues
around race then people have to be given
the opportunity to do that others will
say now hang on a minute the 15 second
sound bite is all that people actually
will hear
and therefore as a civilized society it
behooves people to react
strongly to think about okay twitter and
you'll see this on twitter weren't you
people saying take aways obe
boycott his films etc absolutely
absolutely so let's take down the statue
of winston churchill
who is a white supremacist and a mass
murderer
he's a white supremacist and let's talk
about him talking about
the superiority of the ariel race john
barnes i've just finished the andrew
roberts the excellent andrew roberts
biography winston churchill
uh where it's unequivocal i mean you
know he held the views of his age didn't
he
um does it make him a lesbian literally
and it's totally different liam he held
the view of not only his age the age
that is actually happening now
so what's the difference how is william
churchill a hero
when he spoke about he believes in
guessing the lesser races
but he's a hero and when liam neeson
comes out and he admits that he was
wrong in what he did whereas winston
church would never admit he was wrong
never and he still if he was alive now
he would still believe in the
superiority
of of the aryan race but liam neeson
someone who admits that after a week and
a half of thinking what he thought
he was wrong which is which is fine as
far as i'm concerned we're now we're now
um pillaring him okay i suppose what we
can't do i mean the the the
winston churchill things is a is a
digressionism what we can't do
is judge not only figures by the
morality of today that becomes
problematic
well exactly but you can't judge what
happened 30 years ago you can't jump
liam neeson 30 years ago in terms of the
way he actually thought
because he's not saying this is what he
felt last week he's talking about a long
time ago and he said after a week
he was horrified and ashamed in terms of
what he felt well one thing we can say
with conviction and you may accuse me of
being
a tad cynical for saying this but we are
as a sideline to this we are talking
about the film
so there's some global publicity that's
been generated
you get the sense from listening to what
he's saying it's almost a stream of
consciousness
he's been led to a place he didn't
particularly plan on a goal
people are talking about liam neeson
never working again you think he's done
this because he wants to promote the
film
absolutely not we're now talking about
liam neeson never working again
boycotting his films
and in terms of what the perception
people are going to have of him and you
think he did this on purpose
absolutely not not from his perspective
maybe from the perspective of
the filmmakers or that interview the
woman who gave that interview and then
to suggest as i saw on television
the fact that when he gave his joke
about i've got a particular set of
skills and i will find you and we're
having people
sensible intelligent people now saying
oh i really believe that he threatened
to kill her and that's supposed to be
taken seriously
this is the influence that the media has
in if they want
a particular perception and this is what
has been done to black people for
hundreds of years the perception we may
have
of a particular group of people and the
perception we now have of liam neeson
based on something from my perspective
it's positive and he should be applauded
for saying
yes i was an unconscious racist and
after a week i realized that i was
horrified that i was
and people are going to be afraid of
admitting it now because of what's
happened to liam neeson